okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about substitution and the order of
operations also sometimes referred to as
pemdas
and
these are kind of easy questions but
they're also easy to make mistakes on if
you don't pay attention to the negative
signs and the order of operations so let
me just go through this real quick with
you you've got
four levels of importance so the first
level the first thing you want to focus
on are the parentheses
then the exponents then multiplication
and division they're on the same level
of importance and then lastly addition
subtraction so you want to follow this
order of operations sometimes people
remember this as please excuse my dear
aunt sally these questions usually come
on early in the test
but again it's something you want to pay
attention to not to make a simple
mistake so we're going to go through two
examples and again go ahead and pause
the video see if you can solve these on
your own and then we'll go through them
together so the first one
it says if y equals the square root of
negative the quantity x minus two all
divided by negative four m
find the value of y when x equals 6 and
m equals negative 4. okay so go ahead
and see if you can do this on your own
and we'll go through it together
okay so the first thing i'm going to do
here is i'm just going to substitute now
whenever you do a substitution you want
to think of putting that quantity that
you're substituting in parentheses you
want to treat it as a group so for this
first one we've got y equals the square
root of negative
k and then you can see that x is
6 minus 2 okay all divided by a negative
4
times m which is also negative 4. okay
so see how i put it in parenthesis just
so i take it as a group okay now what
we're going to do is we're going to work
from the inside out so we've got 6 minus
2 which is 4 times this negative is
negative 4. so for the numerator we have
square root of negative 4
and the denominator negative 4 times
negative 4 two negatives multiplied to
give you a positive so that's 16
okay and then the square root of 4 is 2
but the square root of a negative number
gives you the i for imaginary right so
2i all divided by 16 okay and then 2 and
16 you can reduce to
1 over 8. so this is going to be i over
8.
and we're going to talk more about
imaginary numbers in another lesson okay
in this course but again the thing i
wanted to focus on here is just make
sure you follow the order of operations
so let's do another example example
number two
and here you've got y equals this
quantity here find out what y is when x
is negative 3. so go ahead and see if
you can do this on your own
and then we'll go through it together so
let's see here so we've got y equals
negative okay now i'm going to put this
in parentheses negative 3 cubed minus 4
times negative 3 squared
minus 2
times negative 3
minus 8.
okay
now
there's a feature on your calculator
it's the store feature you might want to
check this out what you can do is you
can go like this you can say negative
three
you hit that store key sto
and then hit the hit x okay and so what
it'll do it'll store underneath the
variable x then what you can do is just
type in this quantity just like you see
it here and it will calculate it for you
now that's you can do that on the ti 83
the ti-84
but i'll just show you how to do it here
just using the order of operations so
what you can do is you want to start
with the parentheses and then the
exponents so a negative 3 three times is
going to be a negative okay if it was an
even number like this was 4 then this
would be a positive so you want to make
sure if it's an odd number of negatives
it's negative even number of negatives
it's going to be positive so this is
going to be negative 27
okay
times this negative right okay and then
over here you have a negative 3 squared
so a negative times a negative is a
positive right so that's positive 9 so
that's 4 times 9
and then over here we've got negative 3
minus 8 okay which is negative 11 so we
have minus 2 times negative 11. okay
let's go back now this is going to be
negative times a negative is positive 27
let's see minus 4 times 9 is 36 and then
let's see minus 2 times negative 11 is a
negative 22
or you could think of this as negative 2
times negative 11 which is plus 22
either way would work
and then now we can just simplify so 27
minus 36 is negative 9
plus 22 which gives you how much let's
see is that 14 yeah positive 14.
so
this is kind of a simple lesson but
again just pay attention to the order of
operations do the substitution make sure
you do it by putting it in parentheses
especially if you're doing it on your
calculator sometimes students will make
a simple mistake they'll just say you
know they'll forget to treat it as a
group and if they go like this on their
calculator
let's say they want this to be negative
3 to the fourth power
well the calculator is going to do the
exponent first and then multiply by the
negative second so your calculator will
tell you this is negative 81 when really
maybe what you wanted to do was negative
3 the quantity to the fourth so just to
be on the safe side put that in
parentheses when you're doing a
substitution whether it's by hand or on
your calculator